Uncut version,
any
computer
say
that takes the
people come in and do it on a computer
instead of
have you read his book?
Were there before anything?
Was there time outs of feminine figure
because she's the wife of absolute,
which is also a dragon and it is the
case in the ecology that the figure of
the terrible mother and mother in
general is often contaminated.
Figure dragging.
I don't exactly know
why it is that mythological.
I mean,
most mythological stories described this
creation of the world out of one of two
things.
It's either the body of a giant or it's
the body of a serpent.
I don't exactly know why it's the body
of the serpent or wall or a giant for
that matter.
It's difficult to tell.
It's in part because the serpent is a
serpent that eats its own tail.
That's the era.
So you've been reading about and it's a
symbol of the union of opposites and
from the mythological perspective,
whatever it was that the universe is
made out of.
Before it was discriminatory,
law objects was everything that's now
discriminative,
all combined into one thing and the
assembles that myth uses to the symbols
that myth uses to represent that state,
which by definition can't be
represented,
circulate around attempts to,
to represent the union of paradoxical
opposites.
Um,
apple fest,
for example,
the Egyptian serpent,
the serpent that eats the sun every
night.
It's the serpent that Ray,
who's the son God kills every morning
when he,
when he rises again,
raised the god of the Egyptian,
Pharaoh is assimilated to apple.
FIS for the Egyptians was the god that
was there at before time began and the
same God that will be there after time,
not known at the beginning of time or
the head of time,
but outside of time,
entirely something that surrounds time.
And that's what these fingers are
attempting these fingers here and
getting them to represent the same sort
of idea.
And this is from Ben and in Nigeria,
there's a certain design here in the
serpents in closing the world on a
breast shield.
This is a Mexican calendar stolen within
encircling serpents,
serpents,
head up there.
That's the world.
Again,
the world is the reason the serpent is a
road a year because the year is also the
world mythological language tends to mix
things up.
Again,
it,
it's,
it's very.
It's very frequent for cultures to
regard the creation of the new year as
equivalent to the creation of the new
world.
That's why again as in Sumeria,
and that's an extraordinarily
widespread,
a ritual that the day that the dragon is
dispatched and her parts pulled apart to
make.
The world is also New Year's Day and the
day that the state is renewed,
state is equivalent to the world.
From a mythological perspective,
the state is where order rules as
opposed to chaos.
Chaos has two symbols,
one being the serpent and the other
being the great mother.
The serpent is the most primordial form
of chaos.
It's chaos from which everything else is
engendered.
So you could say there's two types of
chaos.
There's chaos that preceded the division
of order
and disorder,
and there's the chaos that stands for
disorder as opposed to order
in the Samaritan Inn.
The earliest Sumerian creation
mythology.
For example,
world parents arise from the body of the
serpent worth parents on the sky and the
earth.
The earth is assimilated to the female.
Female stands for chaos,
but you have to understand that
once you've circumscribed an area,
say like a state,
the area outside of that state is
conceived of as chaotic.
It's where anomaly roles.
It's where novelty rules was a slightly
different form of chaos that the kind of
cast that proceeded the establishment of
any order whatsoever.
You can see that's kind of a subtle
distinction and I think that's part of
the reason why the figure of the serpent
and the figure of the great mother get
contaminated so easily is the great
mother is novelty from the standpoint of
ordered.
The serpent is novelty before there was
any division between order and chaos.
Okay,
so see if we can take a look at some
representations here.
Here's two more.
This is from Babylonian.
As the ocean ringing world,
you can't see much of worlds in the
middle.
The oceans around the side and there's
just.
You can just see the edges of the
serpent's tail.
There is not much left of them,
there's not much left of the tablet,
and then this is from Italy.
In the 17th century is the four corners
of the world.
The world,
by the way,
is often,
and this is also very difficult to
understand,
the world of orders generally
represented by a symbol that looks like
that.
That's the world.
It's a Mandela.
It's a circle,
is divided into four parts like
paradise.
The paradise in Genesys has exactly that
structure.
There's not phone from which for Rivers
Flow,
the fountains right in the center where
the four rivers divided up into four
parts and it's a circle and that's a
model for Jerusalem and Jerusalem is the
heavenly city,
and the heavenly city of Jerusalem is
the archetype of log,
so to speak,
upon which all actual cities are
predicated.
So they're always built in an attempt to
imitate and having a city.
And that's common model for,
for city construction.
Again,
it seems to be more or less distributed
all around the world.
Now,
the funny thing is my daughter started
drawing the world,
hear about it about three weeks ago.
And uh,
she drew a finger exactly like this.
This is the world she draws and divided
one line with divided and not.
Um,
I just wanted to ask them why a
representation of a chaos before I was
the unknown and the unknown is so
important and why there's such drive to
since from the time when I'm in
representation as possible in the world
would already have been divided into the
unknown and the unknown.
Well,
again,
I think the reason is,
is because
the argument that are trying to put
forth in the next few chapters in this
book is that the thing you need to know,
most of all,
if you think of a story as a map of
meaning,
it's a,
it's a description of behavioral
patterns that are designed to help you
make order out of chaos.
Okay?
In order to generate a story that has
generalized validity instead of one
that's just relevant for a given
occasion,
you may know how to do one thing and you
can teach someone how to do that thing.
But knowing how to do one thing is
nowhere near as useful as knowing how to
generate patterns of knowing things and
I think part of the drive to represent
the unknown per se,
it's part of the overall attempt to come
to a representation of the domain,
so to speak,
of the always present unknown know your
question is why try supposed,
why
is it necessary to generate an image,
say like the serpent rather than an
image of the great mother,
which is just normally.
I don't know exactly the answer to that.
I mean I don't even know if
all I.
all I can say is that as far as I've
been able to determine what people have
done is attempt to represent the source
of things.
And I mean we still do that obviously
scientifically people are more than
willing to speculate about the origin of
things previous to the.
Even the potential established with a
baby or even could have experienced it.
And it seems to me,
well it seems to be just a side effect
or a direct effect of our general
curiosity about everything
once,
once.
So could you say that once we've been
able to define ourselves in time,
we want to have an explanation for all
time?
I would say when it also maybe like,
I don't know about this,
this like I find this stuff very
compelling.
Obviously it seems to me that things
aren't necessarily just attempt to
describe the unknown there right there.
The representations to me seemed to be
accurate.
I don't know where they came from or how
they developed their approximations that
have taken place over thousands and
thousands of years.
I don't exactly know why.
As such as represented as a circuit,
it has something to do with the
conjunction of opposites.
A serpent is something that's wind and
it's something that's on the ground,
so it's a niche.
It's an image of the Union of whatever
it is that's represented by spirit,
which is usually something like
consciousness or the domain that
consciousness hysterical.
That's the masculine will be at least
mythologically speaking.
The fact that the serpent crawls on the
ground gives the feminine aspect because
it's tied to matter.
It can also shed its skin so it can
trips for.
So the mythological symbol is trying to
say that don known as such with
something that combined opposites that
are generally viewed as separate bowl
and that can transform itself.
He can't say anything about it like
it's,
it's a weird category because.
Well loud.
So you attempted to to describe it in
this bowl.
Now something formless he had complete
that existed before heaven and earth
without sound,
without substance dependent on nothing,
unchanging.
What may think of it as the mother of
all things under heaven has doubt
actually.
And it's the,
it's the source of everything from the
perspective of Chinese mythology and he
points out that as soon as you talk
about it,
you're not talking about.
Because as soon as you categorize it,
it's not an attempt to be like a
purposefully obscure.
The point that is being made biopsy for
example,
is that as soon as you try to talk about
something that's uncategorizable,
you've already categorized it.
You've already got away from it.
So we're in a problematic position here
because we're trying to come up with a
representation of something that existed
before any representations were even
possible.
So all I can tell you about her just to
see what the representations are now,
I think the purpose of them was because
we've been attempting to generate a Meta
story as a species,
and the story is how to adapt to the
fact that the result unknown territory.
Remember the dragon has other attributes
to.
I read a book called Grendel,
which was a novel published in the
seventies recently that the debt or the
dragon in there,
there's a mythological character named
Grendel who eats people
and he's constantly attacking this one
king
from deal.
There's a little Scandinavian and it's
written from the perspective of the
monster instead of perspective
perspective of people.
Anyways,
Grendel is this monster eats.
He keeps attacking this kingdom and
eating people and he's completely.
The dragon has made him invulnerable.
You can't be defeated,
but the consequences of his repeated
attacks on this kingdom is the kingdom
starts to fortify itself very,
very heavily because it's always being
attacked.
It as a consequence of spreads his
dominion everywhere.
So it's,
it's a,
it's a morality play.
In that sense.
It says that one of the functions of
constant death,
threat of death is to produce a
tremendous amount of power in response
to it.
Anyways,
there was one point in the book where
grandma goes and talks to the dragon.
This dragon can see the beginning and
the end of time.
He's also involved in vulnerable.
He sits on gold.
That's another attribute of the dragging
say,
well,
I need classic hero mythology that you
hear those optic to go through the
dragon,
right?
As soon as he,
soon as he faces the Dragon,
he gets the gold that the dragon has
drinks back.
That's another.
That's another indication of the
juxtaposition of opposites.
The story is basically telling you what
the dragon is,
something that can devour you,
breathes fire.
After all,
it's a very potent transformative agent.
Annotate eternal.
If you face it,
sits on a treasure,
though.
It's very dangerous.
If you.
If you face the dragons voluntarily,
that's the story of the myth anyways.
If you face the dragon voluntarily,
then you can get the treasure.
Will you bring the treasure back to the
community that it's changed?
That's a story mode adaptation.
That's why those dragons stories pop up
over and over.
It's always sitting on Treasury,
so it's another.
You can see there how that image sort of
blends into the image of the great
mother and it's positive on one hand,
negative on the other.
I think it's a story,
not a habituation,
but exploration generated that
application in many taken another very
archaic notion and that's the notion of
human sacrifice.
I think I talked to you a little bit
about this before.
If you dig down into most cultures,
if you get down to a sufficiently
archaic layer,
you could find a strategy and time
during which that culture practice team
and sacrifices,
that's sufficiently peculiar practice so
that Arthur Kessler,
when he wrote,
he wrote a book called the machine that
was quite famous back in the early
seventies.
He said,
the fact that human beings practice
sacrifice at virtually all levels of
culture,
our culture,
all cultures so far identified was the
indication that there was something
really biologically wrong with us.
That was such an insane thing to do,
but what?
What?
Those cultures that were practicing
ritualistic sacrifice.
As far as I can tell,
what they were doing was acting out the
idea that the thing that was valued most
had to be sacrificed to the unknown in
order for constant adaptation to
continue,
so it was either like the sacrificial
victim was either you could feel him as
a hero because that was often the case,
so he was a hero who who would be killed
and that his body would be distributed
among the crowd and they'd eat it.
That's one ritual of it.
It's just like the Christian mass by the
way,
is exactly the same idea and the notion
was that to to move towards divinity,
it was necessary to incorporate because
that's the most concrete way of putting
it,
incorporate the body or the essence of
this thing that's constantly being
offered up to the unknown.
That was the only way that you could
continue insuring that constant
adaptation was going to take place.
So that's the sacrificial aspect of the
hero.
And then there's also the sacrificial
aspect of the king and those two things
get confused as well.
The king isn't a hero.
The king is the fonder of the hero,
or he's the thing that hero generates.
You can look at it either way.
The king is also something that has to
be sacrificed,
that Kenya is the embodiment of
behavioral patterns that had adaptive
significance in the past.
Also schemas of representation and
they're useful for guiding adaptation,
but if the environment shifts suddenly,
then they have to be changed and the
only way they can be changed as well
from the mythological perspective,
if their sacrifice,
that's what those rituals were trying to
act out now as you can check around in
the literature to two year old,
two year old to satisfy your own
curiosity.
As far as I can tell,
I've never been.
I've never found an explanation.
If you sacrificial ritual that was fun,
prehensile,
that didn't make.
That doesn't fit along that theoretical
line.
So if you can,
if you could accept the argument that
people acted out ideas before they
understood that.
That's what I was trying to explain it.
Part of that neural psychological
chapter,
say evolutionary pressures,
select our behavioral patterns.
We don't invent them all.
If we experiment a lot,
some behavioral patterns last and some
don't,
so I think we get.
We get behavioral patterns that are
established as a consequence of
evolutionary pressures.
They're established long before we can
understand,
so we get the behavioral pattern down.
Then we started watching what we're
doing and when we're watching what we're
doing,
we tell stories and the stories reflect
their first order,
representations of behavioral patterns
that that work so people,
people's that survived were able to give
up the thing that was most important to
them when it was necessary,
and over the course of,
I would say hundreds of thousands of
years,
we gathered enough observations about
success to draw some general conclusions
about what it meant.
We know already in this and obtain by
the Mesopotamian times,
whatever it was that Martech represented
was already positive as necessarily
occupying the highest position in the in
the dominance hierarchy of gods.
So that's already established 5,000
years ago.
By the time people could write.
We knew that story and it's debatable
whether or not we knew what it meant,
but then you have to ask yourself,
when you say that you know what
something means,
what do you,
what do you say in one thing you're
saying is like if you know something,
you can act it out and the fact that you
can act on does not necessarily mean you
have an accurate representation of it or
that you can say anything about it,
words that are or that it was
constructed as a consequence of word
verbally and thinking that it was
rational or any of those things,
knowing something is acting it out and
that's wasted and it's images of wisdom
are collected in mythology.
Far as I can tell.
Otherwise you have to come up with it.
Well,
I mean you can try,
try,
try as you want,
come up with an alternate explanation
for things that on the face of it seems
insane.
Sacrificial rituals.
You have to realize these things have
lasted long time.
When I made allusion to the Christian
mass,
that that's direct light.
When you eat the way for that represents
Christ.
He's the sacrificial victim and the
incorporation of that way for it's made
out of wheat because wheat is it dying
and resurrecting a plant by the way,
so there's a lot of vegetation going,
symbolism that it is assimilated into
that we host.
When you meet that notion is that you're
supposed to incorporate whatever is at
the essence of Christ.
People still do that and so it's a.
it's a symbolic representation of
sacrificial ritual and it's supposed to
produce an effect.
It's got more and more abstract as you
can tell people no actually engage in
sacrificial rituals anymore.
Although we kind of do that and we still
do their new year's.
Say you make your resolutions,
the notion there is the death of the old
self and the birth of the new self and
you see they're still symbols that hang
around you.
The culture from from archaic terms
about the New Year to kind of the old
year who's hobbling along.
He's killed off to make room for the new
year and that's when you're supposed to
formulate your resolutions because
that's a time when you can scrap your
pastor Vernon,
so to speak,
and give rise to a new self.
No sorts of those sorts of rituals.
Those sorts of ideas are very useful.
It's very difficult for people to escape
often from the weight of their past.
That's sort of their accumulative habits
or the way that they construe the world
like there's certain utility and now
because God you as far as you as you are
now,
but there's a tremendous amount of
weight so I can.
I can remember,
for example,
I'm from a very small town and the thing
about being from a small town perhaps
it's not so much different.
The city is that everyone knows you.
When everyone knows you,
you're trapped by your social
representations,
so it's very difficult not to stay who
you were because your behavior is always
modified by those around you into a
shape.
They can predict.
Even if you want to change,
if you leave a place like that.
In fact,
anytime you leave anywhere that's the
changing of your world,
you have a chance to,
to abandon your old personality,
develop a new one.
Anyways,
let me show you some of these
representations.
The only way you can get a feel,
I think for this sort of thing is fine.
What else am I thinking about it?
I want to show you that.
Well,
I'm not sure
how
new year got so far Easter
because Easter shift.
Yeah.
Well Christmas isn't very far with this
place from the new year and the thing is
is that the son is born on the 21st of
December.
That's why.
That's why Christmas Day is so close to
the 21st of December.
So because the days start getting longer
again.
So I guess that's part of the answer is
that the Christian ceremony of Christ's
birth was assimilated to the rebirth of
the sun,
so kind of occupied that space in the
calendar.
That was the.
That was the first part.
Yeah.
I know,
I know.
No,
I don't.
I don't know the answer to that
question.
I do know that's why there are rabbits
and eggs at Easter.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
Right.
I'm not saying that.
Why is,
why is why is in eastern in December.
I'm saying,
why isn't the first day of the year?
I don't know.
I mean,
I,
I don't know.
I knew you could speculate that there's
tension between the two dates.
Rabbit's hole when Easter.
Well,
they're symbols of rebirth.
Takeaway rabbits are symbols of
fertility and ate eggs.
Easter bunny.
What do you think these things come from
somewhere?
The vast unknown,
like I just told you like five minutes
ago,
that we do all sorts of things.
We don't understand.
We act out things we don't understand.
So I tell you what,
the Easter bunny meetings and everyone
laughs because everyone knows about the
Easter bunny and no one has a clue what
it means.
So that's a perfect example of how these
sort of archaic ideas can continue to
exist.
People are absolutely so to speak,
unconscious of the meeting,
which basically means you act them out,
but you don't know what you're doing.
So for example,
of something that
represents rebirth because it's some
sort of an archetype or an example of
something that represents me because
it's been,
well,
it's a,
it's a fertility symbol and it was a
pagan.
It was a pagan symbol of fertility and
as as far as I know,
it just got it just got assimilated to
the Christian festival of eastern hung
long hung around long width and so we
speak and the.
Are they sort to re re chosen as symbols
that chaos that proceeded in division or
or or are they ancient temples that have
simply been pretty simple that we have
today?
That's a good question.
I'm going to show you a bunch of videos
and I don't know the answer to that.
I think personally I think that when
people start thinking about those sorts
of things,
those symbols naturally come to mind
regardless of whether they're passed
down.
Although they are also passed now that
because I can't understand why they keep
popping up everywhere.
Otherwise.
The other thing is this is an argument
that human too.
He said,
he said,
well,
symbols won't for a long time to listen.
Particularly Apropos,
no.
They happen to match some aid priority
concept in psychology,
academic psychology.
We don't give much credence to the
notion of the archetypes of the
collective unconscious,
for example,
that's observed.
That's because that is because we are
unbelievably ignorant historically in
psychology here.
I'll give you an example.
I was reading with and let the other
day,
you know,
when the Spaniards came to the new
world,
they were looking for gold for elder out
of the city of gold.
That's.
That's an analog of paradise.
They're also looking for the fountain of
Youth.
Part of the reason that they ended up
going up north on their trips was
because they met abandoned wandering
Indians who were looking for the same
thing.
The Indians told them a whole set of
stories about where this paradise might
make and away they went.
You.
That's pretty peculiar.
You know,
it's an hour.
I can give you the reference for that.
It's an these book,
the sacred and the profane.
I mean,
it's difficult to account for that.
We can't account for it by by a while.
You could say both ideas came from a
single source,
some tens of thousands of years previous
it'd be like 17,000 years because I
think between 10 and 17,000 years
because I think that's when the native
Americans crossed the land bridge into
North America,
but then you have to explain why those
ideas hung around for at least 10,000
years.
I guess there's a difference between
saying that
or that that determines the shape of our
culture and those ideas.
Yeah.
Well,
I think.
I think what happens is that.
Well,
let's take another take the notion of
the snake,
for example,
like we know that we know that novel
phenomena have the capacity to grip your
attention so then you could say that
any,
anything that has the capacity to grip
your intention would be a useful symbol
for novelty and it's certainly the case
that snakes have the capacity to grip
your attention.
So that might.
That might be the process by which the
symbol's not only originally generated
but renewed when it has to be renewed.
I'll show you a picture of Kelly.
I put it in the manuscript and anyways,
I mean it is the case that innate like
the domain of the novel always appears
to us as simultaneously threatening and
promising with threat having the initial
operation,
if the phenomena is up sufficiently,
have sufficient novelty,
and that's in board,
right?
I mean that's part of the structure of
our nervous system,
our capacity oriented,
unpredictable.
Now
it's also the case that we seem to be
able to generate an effect to things
like snakes easier than we can do things
like electric outlet,
even though the environmental danger of
perhaps being reversed,
so there's,
there's at least a kind of a tendency in
our nervous system to acquire fear to
spiders and to bare teeth and to snakes
and to fire easier than other objects.
So perhaps you don't need much of a,
an underlying biological knowledge to
ensure that a certain class of symbols
constantly gets regenerated.
So
we know the not the novel,
the domain of the novel has the same
attributes that Rudolf Otto wrote a
seminal book in 1946 called the nature
of the Holy Spirit.
The holy phenomena is newness.
That's a word you coined.
It has two aspects,
a fascinating aspect and the terrifying
aspect,
and again,
I think he's really relating to he's
describing the same sort of phenomenon,
is that we're innately compelled to
Orient and Tan and to consider on
inspiring for that matter any
sufficiently dramatic manifestation of
the novel.
It's also the case that it's perfectly
reasonable to make the presumption that
the world is generated as a consequence
of our contact with with anomalous
information because it is.
That is the place where we generate
everything that we take for granted,
including ourselves.
So it strikes me that this is a
relatively mythological perspective,
is it seems to me to be a completely
coherent viewpoint.
Now people say,
well,
the fact that something's coherent
doesn't make its true,
make it true,
and that's certainly the case because
paranoid delusions or coherent,
but theoretically they're not true.
Then you have to figure out what do you
need in addition to coherency?
Well,
that's a tougher.
That's a tougher question.
If you act the story out and your
emotions are arranged in a manner that
you find better subjectively than they
were before,
would you say that that would be
evidence for the efficiency of the
story,
the efficacy of the story for its truth?
Can you just define shoot?
Well,
I'm just wondering like one of the
things I wondered about constantly when
I was teaching my personality class for
example,
is these constant panoply of different
personality theories.
They're all predicated.
They have certain elements in common,
one of them being a necessity to face
those bits of your experience that you
really can't comprehend very well to
face novelty.
That's something that's really core to
them,
but they vary a lot and in the clinical
literature there's a fair amount of
evidence that
there isn't much difference between one
therapeutic approach and another in
terms of their efficiency,
they're all pretty good.
The only thing that's kind of known for
sure is that if you're an eclectic
psychotherapist and you sort of pick and
choose,
you don't do as well as you do if you're
committed to one particular law,
even though it doesn't matter what the
model is.
So then it struck me that while perhaps
the reason for this is that if you go
into therapy and have an incoherent
story,
which basically means you don't know
what direction to go in,
your goals aren't set very well.
You don't have a good definition of
yourself.
That means you're emotions are
dysregulated.
If I give you a story that's coherent,
that's an improvement.
Just the fact that it's coherent is an
improvement over your incoherence story
and maybe there's other the other.
Then the next thing to do what he does
specify what else you need from a story
other than coherence.
And again,
that's what I'm trying to do with this
course.
So what I'm wondering is like we would
say that therapy is effective when the
client says I'm better and when the or
when the therapist says you're better or
when both due or when.
Some other people do,
but the point is it's still,
it's still based on,
well,
when a client says I'm better,
usually what they mean is I'm not going
to commit suicide now,
so I'm going to have depressed.
I'm.
I may be somewhat anxious,
but I think I can handle it or and I'm
nowhere near as anxious as I used to be.
So negative emotion has been brought
under control.
I'm hopeful about the future,
you know,
and I can see that life might be
satisfied.
That means their emotions of being
regulated and that's what a coherent
story does.
Since stories are about patterns of
action that are adaptive,
that make well,
that makes a certain amount of sense
because when we're acting on the
environment,
what we're trying to do is to transform
it into a place where our emotions are
optimally balanced,
where we're not subjected to pain or
anxiety,
where we have hope for the future and
with how we view life is satisfied in
addition to being coherent.
Story should also be relatively stable.
Well,
it has to have two aspects.
It has to be stable,
but it also has the.
It has to have the capacity to update
itself with stability.
That's right.
So the best story is a story about how
the update stories,
when that's necessary,
and that's the story that hero and wild
anyways,
clients
would.
I know.
I wouldn't suggest that.
No,
I would say actually the to the degree
that a therapy is effective,
it acts that out because for example,
in one of the most effective behavior
therapy techniques is exposure,
so to speak,
and what's what exposure is supposed to
do is is producing situation,
which is wrong.
That isn't what exposure does.
If you like.
If someone's afraid of getting into an
elevator,
what you do is teach them behavioral
strategies to transform and elevate it
into something that's positive.
It looks like habituation because
because mostly what they do is model
you,
but that's still what you do it like you
don't have to think.
You don't even habituate to the unknown.
What you do is explore it and classify
it.
It's just that our experiment procedures
have been really poorly constraint.
I think.
So they're trivial to fight.
If you're in the lab and I pay you 100
tones that are the same,
and then the nonvolatile,
we'll orient to that and if I keep
playing it over and over,
you're orienting response to go away and
then I would say,
well,
you've habituated,
that's not true.
What you've done is classify that tone
as meaningless through exploration of
its properties and you have to be
sitting there so your exploration is
really constrained.
That's still what you're doing.
So I would say like an answer to your
question is to the degree that a
therapeutic doctrine is implicitly or
explicitly modeled on this story,
it works to the degree that it isn't.
It doesn't.
We know like what are the major factors
in promoting therapeutic improvement is
exposure to threatening or an almost
information.
So Freud thought something terrible has
happened to you in the past.
That's trauma,
right?
So that's an event that you can't make
sense of for,
you know,
it's hard to define trauma,
but we'll just leave it at that for now.
Freud originally thought that all you
have to do is bring that traumatic
experience up into consciousness.
That was catharsis cured,
but he knew by the end of his life that
that didn't work.
Behavior therapists have said,
no,
no.
You have to warn them.
You have to adjust someone's actions.
So that's the things.
If what a therapist,
a therapeutic system does is expose you
to enormous or threatening information
and make you readjust your behavior as a
consequence to the degree that you did
that,
you're cured.
If you won't do it here.
No,
I don't understand how situation isn't
what you just described as exploring it
and getting used to it.
Well,
habits.
Well habituation usually means something
like getting used to,
but most of the time when you
encountered like you don't just
habituate to a normalist or threatening
information.
If you're getting pounded flat everyday
you go to school saying you're a child,
you did not habituate to that.
The only way that you can get used to
it,
so to speak is to alter your behaviors
or your scheme of representation so that
bullying is no longer pounding on you.
So that means you might have to.
I don't know.
What do you have to do?
Take karate lessons.
Weightlift get a new group of tougher
friends,
bring a knife to school,
something,
but until you transformed the source of
the threat,
then what?
You're not going habitually because you
don't get used to it.
You'd like to turn it into something
positive,
but certainly turn into something
positive.
Could you could turn into something
neutral.
And if you're right,
maybe it stays negative.
Yeah,
neutral is not so bad,
but it's not as good as positive.
So if you're really successful,
it's when,
if it's one thing to chase the dragon
away,
it's another thing to give the gold.
If you're really successful,
you get the goal of chasing the dragon
ways.
That's not so bad.
That's usually what we do.
So
patients with dreams where patient
therapy,
patient dream,
right?
So that would be the patient
that was,
that was his interpretation of
transference,
said because he thought that he thought
in fact the therapy was the ritual.
And the first,
the first,
um,
he thought that what therapy did was
basically initiate
a sequence of activities that were
biologically predicated and that our
capacity to hero worship was one of the
things that lead our,
an outpatient.
So you think you think about this,
I mean,
you know,
the children will,
will hear a worship,
they'll imitate,
imitate their parents,
or they'll pick us child who's slightly
older and act them out,
literally follow them around and
duplicate their actions.
Say they their capacity for all drives
their ability to move behavioral
information from one place to another,
or you just thought he reactivated that
in therapy so that the person would
regard the therapist as well.
For all intents and purposes,
God,
that was all right in a sense because it
could,
it provided some emotional dynamism to
keep the therapy going forward in the
face of the tremendous amount of threat.
Because you need,
you need something that you didn't
already have to overcome the threats
that you couldn't cope with before.
And then you would presume that,
well,
once he died in the dream,
that meant that the thing that the
therapist thought he was had been
[inaudible],
so to speak,
into the person so the person knew what
they had put out there was actually an
attribute themselves,
but know them personally,
but of humanity in general,
when he's in front of a therapist,
provides a story and the therapist would
be story in there for the king and the
hearing process would result in the
death of the king as being the,
the crush story followed by the
possibility of taking on the role,
the crunch store.
You mean to get to get you through the
story just provides.
Yes.
So initially,
yes.
Yeah,
that's right.
Well that's so the dreams is a
representation story of the consulting
firm.
Bain,
right?
Right.
Exactly.
Speaking of which,
I'm going to.
I'm going to show you some images.
It's better to show this in images.
So you guys can read the manuscript and
you can add like,
I'll answer your questions too.
I want to show you this one in
particular just so you can keep it in
mind.
This is an image of the positive
feminine,
by the way.
Green Tara from that.
This is what,
sorry.
That's not very focused.
This is a Mandela.
You have to take my word for it.
Seeing from the side instead of from the
top,
usually go to Mandela is.
It's a square that has a circle
inscribed.
It's divided into four parts.
You see them in wallpaper and on.
Unranked isn't all over the place
anyways.
This is one that if you look from the
top,
it would be a man.
Now you can see the square here,
circle there.
Anyways,
that's Tara.
She's a positive image of the feminine.
She's in this thing of in here.
That's trees.
It doesn't matter.
I love.
The thing that's interesting about that
is that there's a whole creation myth
and this little in this little lot,
this little statue,
that's a turtle.
The turtle on which there are threats.
Out of that comes these two dragons.
We should know a little bit about.
You should be able to see how that
relates to creation mythology,
but anyway,
she pops out at the end.
She's an image of higher consciousness
as well.
Anyways,
the thing or what did he keep in mind is
keys to certain to certain,
like things that accompany your.
I want to show you some Disney
animation.
Great.
Now I'm Mrs Partly Dancer for to address
your question in part.
I mean you said,
you know,
did these images pop up or they
transmitted?
I don't have a clue,
but I'll show you some of them.
This is a really funny one.
This is from the rescuers.
This horrible female gets this little
girl out of the orphanage and she wants
to lower down a well and in the whale
there's diamond in a skull which has no
chemical image by the way.
She lives in a swamp in a row boat.
The swamp is.
That is a favorite place for creatures
of the night in fairy tales and myths
and that's because the swamp is a place
where death is transformed into life.
Straight.
Swamp is eerie because things are dying
rocking here all the time,
but it's also a place where there's a
lot of action.
So anyways,
she's in the swamp.
I'm going to show you a very short brief
on this.
This is more comical than anything else,
but
okay.
All these little avenues.
Okay.
This is where the horrible.
If you would try to
give me my KDP or
teddy goes with me.
Those were her values.
Hmm.
Just do your whole list
on the steering wheel.
No hurry.
Girls and boys that have a real life
character with this creature
anyways,
and so she plays the role to here,
so to speak,
which basically means when a human being
is in its infancy,
he has her,
her infancy there,
obviously very,
very vulnerable to all sorts of external
forces.
So that's,
that's basically all that's making
reference to.
You see this pop up in all sorts of
weird ways.
Superman in the car.
The comment,
by the way,
that became very,
very popular during the depression and
Superman's birth was endangered,
right?
His planet was going to blow up and uh,
he crashed earth and have two sets of
parents as well.
He has the cans who has normal parents
and jewelry.
Hell and all.
Who are his celestial parents and he's
a.
well,
he's a hero obviously.
Andy,
what's that?
I don't know the story of Orphan Annie
very well.
She has.
She's an from the dingy as daddy
warbucks.
Oh yes,
that's right.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's very typical.
That's pretty typical.
So that's making reference to the
parents by the way,
and the divine parents from the
mythological perspective,
our culture,
that's the masculine domain in nature.
That's the feminine domain.
Or You could say the predictable hip and
unknown.
Those.
Those are the two things that give birth
to the hero and the hero is the symbol
of wealth is one of the symbols of the
individual human being.
The fight over the teddy bear seemed
like with the diamond inside seemed like
the sun bug or a newman talks about in
here.
Is that.
Am I getting too far gone?
No,
no,
no.
I didn't pay much attention to the
jewel.
The jewel plays a big role in here
because the jewels in the little teddy
bear that's hers.
And the fight over that.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
it's funny because you see the girl
winds who.
Let me see if I can remember the story
properly.
Um,
like I said,
the girl has to go into a dark.
Well to get this diamond,
it's inside the skull,
so she has to recover fears to get it
and she's getting it for this horrible
woman.
Now the woman has the diamond confused
with what it represents and that's why
she's after that.
So this is a parable about materialism
by the way,
that's when you get the diamond confused
with what it represents.
The little girl actually wins the
diamond,
so to speak,
because she overcomes the great mother
and at the end of the second,
of course the story that's happening
because she's a hero.
She does end up with a family.
She's turned into a real person.
That's basically,
that's basically the moral of the story.
So,
and on that note,
let me show you this one.
Okay.
This is Pinocchio.
And Nokia is a hero myth.
I mean it's,
it's,
it has all the elements of the hero
myth.
The Nokia was not real at the beginning
of the story is made out of what will.
Blue fairy comes down and says,
if you're good,
you can become a real,
a real boy.
And uh,
so then he goes on a series of
adventures and the adventures culminate
in this scene and he,
he's accompanied by this cricket given
crickets.
Who's a,
that's his conscience.
He plays the same role,
you know,
this little cartoon face scenes you see
where there's an angel on one shoulder
and a devil on the other.
Well,
Jimminy cricket is the angelic aspect of
conscience and I've always,
I don't know,
like,
I don't know this and this is just
something that popped into my,
my,
uh,
my imagination,
but his initials are jc and I don't
think that's a flute
anyways.
Okay.
So,
uh,
he's fallen in with bad company.
Okay.
On his adventure.
He's out in the world and it's just
checking.
Okay,
well,
you get the picture there.
That's where he's almost identical story
of the horse and the cirrus.
And why that's the case.
I don't know the history of this
particular story.
Um,
I want to show you just a couple of
overheads here.
The Fisher King,
right?
Just one other comment,
this is the edited version,
the 19 eighties version,
and the original Disney version.
When they were inside the belly of the
beast,
they they decided they were going to eat
the fish,
the little fish,
Cleo,
to stay alive,
and that was edited out.
That might have some sacrificial.
Well,
I don't know.
I didn't know that.
That's an interesting image that's
relevant
in the jaws of hell,
so detail,
but wouldn't acquire stolen friends
anyways,
so that's kind of interesting.
Relevant image,
these
images.
Sixth Century.
That's the cauldron of transformation by
the way,
that the blue angel therapy and that was
a.
she's a symbol of the positive aspect of
the feminine.
No positive aspect of novelty.
Basically it was released as a
consequence of his voluntary represents
the dragon.
Remember Marta curves the world of
timeout.
Timeouts.
This dragon that lives at the bottom of
the ocean.
Same thing happens in the Hebrew Bible
to it's varied.
It refers to a much more archaic
tradition.
You have a three makes the world out of
it as a consequence of dabbled with the
monster that's variously known as ray
habit and Leviathan.
How if I have the hair of this section
is written down,
but my computer crashed today and I
didn't bring them in so I can get you
the references if you want for
references and various places
in the old testament while there's some
mostly in the old testament.
Yeah.
It's also the case.
This is interesting too,
is when Jehovah threatens to lay various
territories,
waste,
which he does with certain mode of
regularity,
he always describes the territory that
will remain after everything's
devastated as fit habitation for
serpents.
So again,
it starts the story of the reduction of
the order flakes.
Chaos and chaos is the place that's fit,
habitation for surface and anything that
lives there is assimilated to a circle.
So I'll get you the quotes.
I collected them all last two weeks ago.
Actually,
I have the King James Bible on CD role,
which is really useful because you just
put in whatever your word is and it
gives you every single reference to the
whole text,
so there's.
Well,
he collected a whole sequence of
references from various cultures that
will bring them in and show you,
so this is an interest in
reverification of the sacrifice ram
baptism imagery.
That was what Pinocchio,
just on your way and the fact that you
can say,
well back.
The baptism rituals we have now,
which are pretty trivial Christian ones
anyways,
a pretty jovial,
so in some some sex in the southern us
in particular dip people completely into
the intuit river,
signifying your second birth,
generally just sprinkled with water,
but what that is is a very.
It's a remnant from a ritual that was
much harder,
much more dramatic that his finger went
through in the Disney cartoon by two
year old son.
Watched that.
By the way,
he was quite impressed with that.
We'll be talking about that for a good
long time.
He started out about a month and a half
ago and he still talks about that.
We'll set the bottom of the ocean.
It was pretty impressive.
So I can remember too from from bio,
he chose the image of the inside of the
whale.
It's almost like a cathedral that stuck
with me,
if I can remember that when I watched
this.
So that's the second rebirth.
That's voluntary.
Hey,
that's the reason that Nokia was turning
into a boy when you hit,
when he was well on his way to becoming
a jackass was because he decided
voluntarily,
first of all,
to jump into the ocean and the ocean.
That's another symbol of the chaos that
sort of precedes creation.
He is a great symbol.
I mean that is where life came from.
After all.
Here's one from Peru,
dragon fight heroes there.
There's the dragons got fish like
features here as well.
Human Nature.
Yeah.
The respirators.
Why did they,
why were,
why were there two alligators?
And also the,
uh,
the
reference to,
to is,
is the reference.
It's a reference to the world parents
set.
The serpent separates into two things,
order in chaos.
I don't exactly.
That's about the best I can give to that
stuff.
The negative mother often appears
associated with a serpent time for mass
because as I said,
as far as I can tell,
I've been trying to puzzle this time.
It's because the.
It's not that easy,
easy to distinguish the chaos that
existed opposition from order to the
chaos that proceeds over the division of
order and chaos again,
they get mixed together.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
that's a great.
That's a great time.
That's a great picture on the night
scene journey.
So he's assimilated to the sun because
it's the son that goes through the night
seizure every office.
By the way,
the myth of system.
This is all being assimilated to the sun
and you remember that diagram I showed
you.
Things descending into chaos and then
being reborn.
Well,
that's a solar imagery as well.
Anyways,
this is a great emergency.
Okay,
so he's out there in the night in this
cauldron.
He's wearing the skin of a line or lines
of solar beast for all these reasons.
It's yellow.
It's in Africa called or study.
It's sort of upstarting,
typical masculine characteristics.
Even though it turns out that it's
female lines to actually do most of the
other thing,
in reality,
he's carrying a club,
right?
That's his weapon.
His eyes were very wide open.
He's conscious,
fully coded signals was doing see the
club,
these things on the club.
Those are our eyes.
So it's more for symbolism of
consciousness.
So he's up to defeat the monster that it
inhabits.
Unexplored territory territory before
it's being transformed into the place
where real human beings can live.
So.
Okay,
let me show you some others.
So we looked at the rescuers,
right?
Yes.
But then he rides from.
He was from Australia,
you know,
it gives kind of scary.
So by that time it's more or less
inevitable.
So yeah,
he tries to give it away so it's funny.
So I don't know what to make of that.
Exactly.
Accepted by that time.
It's too late to turn back.
It's funny too because his conscience is
more or less warning them against the
Jenny Craig is warning them against
doing it,
but it also helps them tie the state.
It was a real cute touch.
So let's see.
So we have,
well,
well maybe we'll do this one.
Some of you have seen the sleeping
beauty clip.
I used it,
my personality class,
so we'll do the little mermaid instead.
So you can see the assimilation of the
feminine character.
Okay.
Now
Ariel wants to become a real human
being.
Same sort of same time.
She's also a like to to surface.
They're not hurt their personally
eels.
Look at the structure she goes into.
This is very interesting.
It's a portal portal.
Imagery defines the border between chaos
and order.
That's another reason why the feminine
is often used to symbolize the chaos
because the female is the border between
the place that creation takes place and
the real world.
That's the most fundamental reason of
heroes.
Often climate in the body,
the value of the feminine,
the Feminine Needs.
Okay,
so
those are soils that the negative mother
was gone.
I'll
just be in social personality
disorder.
The same thing happen to them as
happened to the boys that were turned
into donkey says
they've made errors.
These choices
is the fitting room.
I'm gonna stop this for a minute.
One of our students last year asked me
why ask me some questions about these
negative feminine new images and why
they were often sexual,
especially in Disney movies then occurs.
They're very concerned with beauty.
For example though,
she's.
She's kind of grotesque,
but figure out a snow white's mother,
which is sleeping,
but they're usually older child the
swimming and I read that as a symbol of
the sacrifice of the child to the
maintenance of youthful.
That's what childless,
that's what child listens.
Representative needs in these stories.
So for example,
Snow White's mother,
very concerned that she's the most
beautiful.
She's the stepmother.
She's never,
she's never.
She's never had children and the way
that myth dot reeves,
that basically as far as I can tell us
that that's equivalent to the devouring
of children who sacrifice of children
to.
But.
And that's what makes these fingers sort
of both beautiful and and horrifying at
the same time.
They're attempting to hold on to a
domain that's,
I guess not right there.
Yeah.
She's,
she's clearly assimilated to conserve.
That becomes even more clear later time.
So she's going to,
she's offering area of bargains.
What
I do,
unfortunately have
no one else did
in the past
when they called me.
Well,
nowadays I've mended all my ways.
Repentance,
which is handy.
I always have to say
I use it on behalf of the
state,
wants to get the girl and do
so
now it's happened once or twice the
price and I'm afraid I have to
put all the whole life of
a human
for three days.
Three days.
You get derailed.
He's got to kiss,
kiss,
kiss you.
You remain human,
but it doesn't
give
you
a
choice.
Oh,
we haven't discussed this.
This is
what I bought from your way is
sweet cakes.
No more talking,
singing
voice,
and don't
get fired
for ladies,
not to say a word on that.
He
was withdrawn and she.
Oh
bosses.
She's.
The funny thing about this movie is this
know she's pretty horrible character,
but it is.
It is because of her in the middle
assists that Ariel does get what she
wants.
She wants to.
She wants to be human.
So
I mean,
what would you.
What does that mean?
Well,
she's,
she's not really.
She's a subterranean creatures.
He doesn't
know what the equivalent is for being in
the ocean.
She's not real,
so she's.
She wants to be transformed into
actuality.
I guess just going to know
what does it seem like she has to
sacrifice something to get what she
wants.
Well,
because you have to sacrifice something
to get you.
That's.
That's the sacrificial motif in part
there.
I mean,
that's the thing she values most,
right?
Is their voice in this particular.
In this particular scene,
walking,
walking legs,
is that each step?
Does she get her voice back?
Yeah.
It's hard for me to tell exactly where
to start this because of this machine
doesn't have any place.
You have
to
make
some
pretty serious boats.
Married the wrong woman
because she has Ariel's voice.
Why don't you just watch
the sun set?
Remember that's her domain,
right?
Because she's the creature that eats the
sun.
Some dogs are
very precious
exchange.
Someone
lost her.
Once
again,
monster bites the dust.
No,
the king is released.
Again,
this is typically goes into the belly of
the beast.
He freeze.
Those people were there and basically
what that means is that he's established
a new pattern of behavior or an
adaptation or a new frame of reference
that enabled people will be defeated by
the unknown,
threatening I know to well to start
their life again,
because you have to remember that the
nature of the unknown,
which is to say the nature of your
experience
is absolutely dependent on how you are.
Okay,
well,
I'll lead to the age of 63,
12,
3:00.
Um,
I wanted to show you all those things so
that when you go through the next couple
of chapters,
you're sort of building up a storehouse
of images too,
because the only way you can understand
this stuff is to
get the images down basically.
So you're also reading a great mother
right now.
See,
this is a union vote.
Fundamentally,
our students both young and none of them
believed that the great mother was a
representation of the collective
unconscious.
I think they're wrong in a sense.
It's a great mother,
is a representation of novelty,
is just so happens that the phenomena
that young subsumed under the rubric of
the collective unconscious are the,
you could say,
or the first r is the first line of
defense that people erect against the
unknown,
which is basically to say that if
something unexpected happens,
you start imagining what it might be.
So the imagination,
what we would normally refer to as the
imagination,
its constituent elements.
That's what you identified as the
collective unconscious.
So all I'm saying basically is that if
something unexpected happened to you,
it always occurs into some form of
representation.
So,
and it's that form of representation
that you identified as the collective
unconscious.
So he would say novelty as such,
would adopt the aspect of Kelly,
for example.
Anyways,
I think that the book makes more sense.
The theory makes more sense in general,
if you understand the great mothers,
the archetype of novelty,
unknown territory behind your sits the
dragon.
So that's true.
Uh,
yeah.
I just was looking in the book the other
the other day and I saw the euro burst.
Describe as a representation of
consciousness.
How do you think that that is?
Because the consciousness comes out of
the finger that.
Well,
the thing is the reverse is the source
of the subject and it's not.
It's not a symbol for consciousness per
se.
It's a symbol for the origins of
consciousness.
The place that it comes from,
you know,
I was just looking through.
His book is called the Silverware
University,
but well people take liberties with the
symbols.
That's the problem is that they do tend
to.
They do tend to mail and across
categories.
It's not because they have fuzzy
borders.
They do tend to blend into one another.
Not knowing anything else about the
book.
I wouldn't say that the statement that
the of burroughs is the symbol for
consciousness is wrong.
It's
so
what's
the father representing consciousness.
Okay.
Just for the record,
before the represents,
there's.
There's two domains of masculine
symbolism and mythology.
Once the hero wins the father,
before that gives rise to the hero,
which is to say that you're a product of
your culture,
but the hearing also gives rise to the
farther,
which is to say that culture is a
product of the activity of the
individual.
So in Pinocchio,
I would still say that Japan was
assembled,
symbolize more what we would consider
the domain of the state or culture and
Nokia with the forest that revivified
yeah,
for Jimminy cricket.
And
so it's kind of like consciousness is
referring to
save his consciousness and what he's
doing.
He referred to him as the son in the
movie.
He's not.
No.
Oh,
I see.
No,
he's not saving his consciousness to see
Japan and notion tells him to save
themselves.
So like Pinocchio takes the more
difficult route,
which is the simultaneous,
I would say from a mythological
perspective,
the simultaneous regeneration of
culture.
So what are the things that you all
pointed out?
Was there any personal problem that's
taken far enough in terms of cultural
problem and if you do a thorough job of
solving your personal problem because
many people share that problem with you.
I mean it's very rare that you'll have a
broad mix you so unique to you that
doesn't also affect that whole a whole
sequence of people who live at the same
time as you do.
If you really solved that problem
symbol,
fantasy or update your culture and
that's what that was.
That's what that story was referring to.
That's why.
See,
that was a sufficiently heroic endeavor.
So the Pinocchio got awarded by becoming
real.
He didn't just do the thing that was
best for himself in the narrow sense.
He also did the thing that revivified
his father.
The thing that made him like literally
an obedient because he was made out of
wood better was a master craftsman.
So Japan,
Oh,
stands for accumulated wisdom basically
that,
that can become stultified but is
nonetheless necessary to sort of drag
along,
so to speak.
So it depended on the positive aspect of
the known.
Yeah.
And the in that particular.
That's right.
He's the guy who forgot,
I can't remember his name,
but the one who ran the pleasure alum or
the boys that the negative aspects.
That's right.
See a name that the boys who misbehave,
who didn't follow,
the coaches who were abandoned by their
conscious never no longer spoke to them.
They were transformative to jackasses
and became slaves.
That's right.
He was the negative aspect of culture.
So the euro is transformed by flooding.
I mean they're both transformed,
right?
While to hear.
Exactly.
It's a process of mutual transformation.
You see in the Cirrus Horace Smith,
which is the myth that IED,
the Egyptian Pharaoh for Onyx stape was
predicated on is the pharaoh is both
Osiris and horus simultaneously,
and that's because the pharaoh,
if like the Dan Pharaoh,
the pharaoh just died instantly
assimilated to ocirus,
but the live feral,
that's horace.
He's both though horace and ocirus.
Simultaneously I take,
well,
that's confusing.
Is the dead pharaohs ocirus.
How can the live feral deal?
Sarah Sound Horace,
but those cirrus is the wisdom of the
past,
and horace is the process that faces the
unknown and constantly updates the
wisdom of the past and both of those
together make the Pharaoh and that
that's right.
I mean the Egyptians had it right.
If there's an act that the state is an
active process,
plus the accumulation of knowledge and
the process is adaptation in the face of
the unknown,
adaptation to the unknown,
and that was symbolized by these
monsters,
that key necessary monsters that keep
popping up for the law and these stories
that we looked at today.
Who is the nicest
mean?
Who?
What does she?
I can't remember her.
She probably just don't remember what it
is.
Oh,
well,
she's the one who reassembles cirrus.
Once he's cut apart,
I think if I remember correctly,
said seth capsule,
but Warner was conflict with seth,
but isis scatters up his pieces.
So she's a,
she's an image of the closet and
feminine.
I don't remember her developmental
history.
I don't remember who she is.
Assimilated.
So she's an aspect.
Yes.
Isis is.
Isis is
another.
Right?
Right.